meet msn - its Airbus's mock-up of the
a350
kind of like as show-and-tell for
airlines AKA potential customers
uber says it offers superior levels of
passenger comfort boeing said pretty
much the same thing when the Dreamliner
started flying back in 2011 so how do
these rivals stack up on the inside a
cabin width of 5.6 meters means airlines
will really be able to pack them in bad
news for cattle class travelers the a350
has a 10 across seating option the
Dreamliner has a max of 9 across it's
just narrower than its rival breathe
easier on an a350 fly thanks to a new
aeration system it changes the air
inside the cabin every three to four
minutes lower cabin pressure of 6,000
feet makes for a more comfortable ride
Dreamliners have the same lower air
pressure too but are also equipped with
special filters to suck up those smells
from food or that guy sitting next to
you who just took off his shoes taking
cues from the euro disco scene the a350
has a full LED lighting system that has
16 million color options hopefully not
all in operation at once
fancy illumination must be a thing on
long-haul aircraft because the
Dreamliner sports it - its lights can
mimic sunrise and sunset